now he was there to commentate on the
return of Test match cricket but when
rain delayed play Michael holding
instead delivered a powerful and moving
speech on race the Sky Sports pundit and
legendary West Indian fast bowler fought
back tears as he called for an end to
institutional racism and for meaningful
education on black history you can tell
me who invented the light board by
Thomas Edison right
everybody knows Thomas Edison invented
the light board Thomas Edison invented a
light bulb with a paper filament it
burnt out in no time at all can you tell
me who invented the filament that makes
his light shine throughout nobody knows
because a black man I was not taught in
schools
Lewis Howard Latimer invented the carbon
filament to a low lights to continuously
shine who knows that everything should
be taught when you go back to the
schooling as a young man I remember my
school is I was never taught anything
good about that people and you cannot
have a society that is brought up like
that both white and black that only
teach what's convenient to a teacher
history is written by the Conqueror not
by those that are conquered history is
written by the people who do harm not by
the people who get harmed and we need to
go back and teach both sides of history
and until we do that and educate the
entire human race this thing will not
stop the treaty keep on tell me there is
nothing called white privilege give me a
break
I don't see any white people going into
a store on Oxford Street a bit followed
a black man walks in somebody's falling
in everywhere he goes that is basic
white privilege whether that white
person when did they rob the place or
not is not when we thought of that we
and things like that have to change
extraordinary stuff and Michael holding
joins me now from Southampton good
evening Michael thank you for being with
us now you've done a lot of commentary
but that right there was possibly the
most powerful thing
that you have said what impact do you
hope it has well mark thanks for having
me thanks for giving me the opportunity
again to talk to the entire public in
the world about this thing I would hope
MA that is not just something that
people have heard and they will just
brush it under the carpet and eventually
just move on I would hope that people
understand exactly what I'm saying and
that understand exactly where I'm coming
from with what I am saying I'm 66 years
old I'm no kid I have been through it
I've seen it and I've experienced it
with other people and as I said as a
young man I was very selfish I just said
to myself if that's not affecting me
I'll just walk away no big thing but
when you realize it's affecting so many
different people over the world and then
when you realize you see with your own
eyes the victimization you just can't
keep on you're sayin you're gonna walk
away and forget it because it doesn't
affect you and that's why I had to say
what I said it was not planned they
don't call it reign of obviously the
video was planned the videos were
recorded about a week or so before we
came to South Hampton but I had it all
pent up inside of me and I just had to
see it yeah I mean it was unscripted
obviously and from the heart and but
your appeal was about education for
history when taught to include the white
perspective and the black perspective
definitely mark cook you see if you go
back to many many years many centuries
the entire world and society was built
on white people white people did
everything and whatever you're taught in
school I spent about nine years at high
school I was not bright so I spent a
lotta time at high school what I was
never taught anything about anything
that a black person that was did that
was good and when you grow up and that
is inculcated in you that everything
good is done by the white man or
anything bad is done by a black man it
cannot be good for your health mental
health I'm talking about your kids
growing up that they think they have
absolutely no chance of achieving what
other
kids their same age but just to that
different skin color has achieved and
that can't be good
I can give you many stories and examples
I give some when I was speaking
yesterday about the different studies
that were done at Yale University this
is not just some little universities
from backwoods Yale University did these
studies and it is covered the
institutionalized racism that is going
on it cannot continue like this we have
to understand that people are people
okay you want to write a book about the
history of your people
what about explaining everything about
that history everything not just what is
suitable to be explained yeah and your
own personal experience since you've
been playing cricket
have you experienced racism on the
cricket field not by cricketers I've
never had one cricketer anywhere in the
world that has passed a racist remark to
me never ever but of course I spend most
of my time though I'd finally gotten
third man and you know what people in
the stands will see so you hear it but
never ever has a cricketer pass the
racism up to me because I wouldn't have
stood for it anyway but what about wider
society what about just your normal life
on the streets of the UK lots mark lots
lots lots you know I I can tell you
about so many things that have happened
to me here in the UK and even in
Australia where I've been in South
Africa since I started going down there
lots of things I'll give an example of
each place here in the UK I was with the
lady that is know my wife who is
Portuguese backgrounds that means that
she's white and I was standing beside
her in in Leicester Square greeting on a
taxi we had just gone to China tonne to
get a meal came back out get trying to
get a taxi the taxi was heading in our
direction with his lights on I stepped
out to put my hand in the road for the
taxi driver to stop he turned off the
light that's not only me I see it so I
talked to friends of mine years ago he
turned off the light and when he passed
me turned it back on and a West Indian
English guy West Indian background
across the street saw me show
to me record and I said Mikey you have
to put her in front which is meaning put
the white lady in front because he the
guy was tough for the white lady and I
showed it back to him I'll walk first
that is this country Australia West
Indies team we were down there in the
eighties a group of us were in the lift
because whenever we go to Austria
langostino hotel they put the entire
team on the CM floor so about four or
five of us got into the lift to go down
into the lobby in stopped on the floor
below once the doors opened and on
Austria and a white Austrian guy stood
there sauce in the lift and decided he
was not gonna come into the lift
okay if you feel intimidated by four big
black guys fine the lift door starts to
close and his shot sorry system ah just
as the doors closing so we just laughed
we've got own little Lobby we go over
way that's Australia yeah don't you
South Africa no the first time I went to
South Africa I went with Sky I went
there on my own the second time I went
world cup again with my wife see him
white lady or skin white Portuguese
background we stood at the lobby trying
to book in a guy came to me try to book
me in and somebody walked up to her
immediately to try to book her in
because in their mind she could not be
with me
and that's the sort of thing what we
laugh about those things because when
I'm not living in the society I just
laugh about it sometimes I agree
misleading my head and I move on but I
cannot keep on laughing grimacing and
moving on it's time for change
so my question I think is you know after
what's happened to George Floyd and all
that has followed from that Sir Michael
do you think the time is right now could
this be the moment where things can and
possibly do change
I think it can I think that definitely
is the moment I've seen so many positive
things since that George flight
situation mark I made a comment about
the amount of white people that I see
are
in these protest marches some protest
marches are more whites than blacks I
think that's a huge plus for this
movement one thing that I a friend of
mine even sent me on whatsapp today
there's a gentleman in the United States
a blood stock agent who posted some
racist remarks on his private whatever
Facebook what I don't know what to do is
I'm not a big guy on social media but it
became public Keeneland
racing industry banned him immediately
he neared the he nor the company he
represents the horses history and the
seller by Django the Keeneland this year
shortly after that his son posted on
again some social media that it's his
father he's ashamed of what his father
did but in a way he is glad because for
the last 20 years he has been trying to
have this conversation with his father
about his racist remarks and he says
he's so glad to a degree that it
happened so he can no actually sit down
with his father and say listen this is
what you have been doing this cannot
right this is his own son and he came
out to the post criticizing his fraud
and said is glad he can no sit down with
them and discuss it yeah I see the
possibility of change and this is not
just a few people talking a few people
marching for we are - I think with the
even companies mark the company we are
working for no they have pledged 30
million pounds towards this thing this
campaign and I see a lot of other
companies doing that and that is the
most important thing right look at
people on the street walking up and down
and not going in a particular shop that
is important yes but you need big
corporations about this thing all right
just two more questions going on from
what you say it's gonna take an enormous
effort from everybody talking about
having people in decision black people
in decision-making positions in sport in
business in politics this is gonna take
a long time and it may just be that you
know everything goes back to normal
I would hope it won't go back to normal
I hope that train will just keep on
moving and yes I know it's gonna take a
long time I am six to six years old I
may not see myself what I'm hoping for
is future generations that they will all
have equality my grandson for instance
he's six years old I hope that when he
gets to be a man that they're mean
nothing about black and white and brown
and pink it will just be human being
that everybody gets an equal opportunity
depending on your skills not the color
of their skin or their race or ethnicity
are what their religion that is what I'm
hoping for that's a big hope but I'm
hoping that we are moving in the right
direction and eventually we'll get there
this thing has been going on for decades
or centuries mark so I don't expect
overnight change but it has to start
somewhere and hopefully that will just
keep on rolling a bit at a time a bit at
a time you cannot change what are
watches in people's heads overnight as I
said yesterday a lot of it is not people
thinking negatively it is something that
is seeps in almost like osmosis into
your mindset that's the day that I
related to with the preschools you know
teachers who automatically look for the
blood kick black kids to be misbehaving
they were embarrassed when they were
told that's what they did because this
is not conscious it is not something
that they consciously think about but
when you live in a society and you live
in that environment you automatically
get it into your head the son of that
blood stocky agent he said that that is
what his father taught him yeah that is
not something that he was born with
nobody's born with it but if you don't
have the people to teach it and
eventually it will just die away as I
said I will be around to see it what I'm
hoping for future generations well the
one last thing Michael at the end of
your improv chi speech at the end of
your impromptu speech yesterday you
seemed visibly upset how difficult was
it emotionally I mean in the middle of a
rain delay at a cricket match on live
television to be honest that emotional
part came when I started thinking of my
parents and it's coming again Oh
mark I know what babyrage red - all
right take your time Michael take take
take the time
my mother's family stopped talking to
her because her husband was too dark I
know what the way true and that came
back to be immediately
all right Michael we'll look
extraordinary stuff yesterday and thank
you very much for being with us today
and as you say it may be the moment it
may be the moment that things change and
you obviously you obviously hope so well
it's gonna be a slow process mark what I
hope even if it's a baby step at a time
even snails pierce but I'm hoping it
will continue in the right direction
even steel Spears I dog here okay
Michael appreciate you joining us and a
difficult subject but something you
wanted to talk about thank you very much
for being with us Michael my pleasure